We’ve lit the fuse on a population bomb
that will wipe out all of humanity. There
is no tomorrow. Mass starvation and genocidal
wars over dwindling finite resources -- the
long-prophesied Norse Ragnarok, the Abrahamist
Last Judgment, the Nuutungk Talongvaqa, the
Hopi Tribe’s “Last Day.” If you're an
attractive, charming doomsday showman, the
end is near.
And if you're a nerd whose best work solved
the problem of airline overbooking, things
have never been better.
Because Armageddon is not just mythological
-- it’s a battle of science, nature, human
behavior, and two men: one, a Goliath celebrated
with academic accolades and public popularity,
the other, a David relegated to relative obscurity.
It’s the story of a bet that bound them
together eternally, a bet over a handful of
natural resources that served as a proxy for
our destiny. The lessons we learned from it
have almost been entirely ignored because
they defy every instinct we have about how
to survive.
The foundational question of their wager is
more relevant now than ever: are we paradoxically
killing ourselves by existing?
And if the facts say everything you think
and feel is wrong, would you even care?
“The battle to feed all of humanity is over.
In the 1970s and 1980s hundreds of millions
of people will starve to death in spite of
any crash programs embarked upon now. At this
late date nothing can prevent a substantial
increase in the world death rate.”
In 1968, Paul Ehrlich opened his doomsday
prediction book “The Population Bomb”
with those three sentences. Ehrlich was, and
still is, an entomologist -- his particular
field of study is butterflies, and 4 years
before publishing a book that would change
the world, he popularized a theory of ‘coevolution’
-- the concept that natural selection doesn’t
happen in isolation, and that plants and insects
can have a reciprocal relationship affecting
both their evolutionary paths.
He’d spent decades thinking about how the
world and all the matter and life within its
ecosystem worked -- minerals, water, plants,
animals, humans -- and he concluded that it
didn’t. Or, that it didn’t anymore. He
saw the end of the world as we know it, and
he not only knew why it would happen, but
he also knew how to stop it.
When he was catching butterflies as a kid
in 1930’s New Jersey -- his collection grew
so large that it filled his bedroom and he
had to sleep in a different room -- he had
no idea that his life was on a collision course
with a boy born in the same year living just
a few miles away. Julian Simon’s interest
was ultimately in economics, and the clash
between Ehrlich and Simon was a decades-long
debate to decide the fate of humanity… and
you.
It’s a debate over morals, mankind, and
math -- and nearly 200 years before the public
wager between Paul Ehrlich and Julian Simon
became the most famous bet in history, it
started with a political economist whose students
affectionately referred to as “web-toe.”
Thomas Malthus focused on economics and demography.
In his 1798 “An Essay on the Principle of
Population,” Malthus wrote that:
“It has been said that the great question
is now at issue, whether man shall henceforth
start forwards with accelerated velocity toward
illimitable, and hitherto unconceived improvement,
or be condemned to a perpetual oscillation
between happiness and misery, and after every
effort remain still at an immeasurable distance
from the wished-for goal.”
OKAY.
His life span almost perfectly covered the
beginning and end of the Industrial revolution,
and he was at the center of it in Great Britain.
It was an unprecedented period of innovation
-- for the first time, machines operated by
a growing urban population wove textiles,
which were then traded throughout a global
market of raw materials and finished goods.
Improvements in mining and refining made iron
production soar, and after 100 years steam
power had finally matured. Life was getting
better… fast.
But if you watched my video on Ignaz Semmelweis
and the disgusting state of medicine in the
early 1800’s, you know that it was also
quickly getting worse. Despite all these material
improvements and increases in overall wealth,
human suffering seemed more severe than at
any point in history. Poverty, disease, and
strife ravaged the lower classes of the England
that surrounded Malthus -- and the environment
was being degraded, too.
The River Thames had been the lifeblood of
the Southeast of England since before Julius
Caesar’s invasion -- and Malthus watched
it turn into a cesspool in real-time. Factories
dumped waste directly into the river, including
tannery chemicals and animal parts from slaughter
houses. Garbage was also just thrown in because
-- why not? It’ll just wash away -- and
it was the perfect outlet for human sewage.
Treating the Thames like a living dumpster
and infinite toilet killed wildlife, made
London stink, and fueled cholera outbreaks
that killed tens of thousands at a time.
And it really STUNK -- July and August of
1858 is known as “The Great Stink,” and
Michael Faraday described The Thames as “feculence
rolled up in clouds so dense that they were
visible at the surface.”
The point is that Malthus was witnessing progress
that even his grandparents couldn’t have
fathomed -- and he was also seeing misery,
social and biological putrefaction, and an
obviously unsustainable future.
He concluded that the problem was people:
there were simply too many of them to feed.
He wrote:
“It is an obvious truth, which has been
taken notice of by many writers, that population
must always be kept down to the level of the
means of subsistence.”
To Malthus, the math is what made the threat
of overpopulation so obvious -- and the “Mathusian
catastrophe” came down to comparing exponential
growth to linear growth. Malthus argued that
the human population left unchecked grows
exponentially, because… people like having
babies. In the 1700s, women of the lower class
tended to have about 8 children, with maybe
5 of them reaching adulthood. If 2 parents
produce 5 kids, and each of those produce
5 more, and each of those produce 5 -- your
family grows from 2 to 7 to 32 to 157 in just
4 generations -- that's an increase of 7,750%
in the human footprint.
And it was an economic problem, too: the more
people, the more available labor. The more
labor, the lower the wages. And the lower
the wages, the harder it is to get increasingly-expensive
food that everyone is competing over.
Contrast that with an increase in food production
that is not exponential -- according to Malthus,
the available farmland can only produce so
much food. So, people must starve by the millions
to restore the balance. He wrote, “Subsistence
increases only in an arithmetical ratio,”
and that was that -- in the battle of geometric
vs. arithmetic progressions, the geometric
side is going to win.
Malthus tried to depict “man as he really
is, inert, sluggish, and averse from labour,
unless compelled by necessity.” To him,
humanity was dumb and lazy -- especially the
poor.
As Malthus wrote the Principle of Population,
England was the pinnacle of modern civilization
-- but it was also in the wake of having suffered
through a costly Seven Years War, the loss
of its American empire, and the day by day
threat of instability and conflict from Napoleon
Bonaparte’s France. If everything that got
better also made things worse in the greatest
country in the world, why would he have an
optimistic outlook on the rest of humanity’s
future?
In 1971, Paul Ehrlich agreed. He said, "By
the year 2000 the United Kingdom will be simply
a small group of impoverished islands, inhabited
by some 70 million hungry people. I would
take even money that England will not exist
in the year 2000.”
In 1980, Julian Simon noticed that England
seemed to be doing just fine, and that what
Ehrlich saw as a set of problems destined
to threaten the fate of humanity were actually
an incredible opportunity.
The really interesting thing about Julian
Simon is that he started out agreeing with
Ehrlich. In the 1960’s he published articles
arguing the importance of family planning
-- encouraging people to limit births -- on
economic grounds. His path to economics was…
circuitous. He studied experimental psychology
at Harvard, where he drove a cab, sold encyclopedias,
and played poker to support himself. He also
worked in a tin can factory, a grass seed
factory, and a brewery, so he knew dirty work
and manual labor -- and he knew the problems
with both.
After college he enlisted in the Navy and
spent time in some of the less-glamorous working
ports of the world where he saw the struggles
of poorer populations and the positive and
negative impacts of mechanization. He left
the Navy and took an interest in business
and economics, studying in a University of
Chicago department energized by the work of
Milton Friedman and Friedrich Hayek. Through
the 60’s and 70’s he noticed that the
lives of the most vulnerable people in the
world were improving, and he did what virtually
no academic does now: changed his mind.
Just like Malthus, it’s important to understand
the time in which Simon and Ehrlich kicked
off their debate. When Ehrlich published The
Population Bomb in 1968, the world was one
generation removed from the most terrible
and destructive war it had ever seen -- total
military and civilian deaths from World War
2 and its effects were more than 80 million,
and the war ended with the debut of the most
terrifying weapon ever created. We’d spent
the 20 years since worrying about which of
the two global superpowers would use it on
the other.
Meanwhile, in the United States, social conflict
drove riots in major cities, the last president
had been assassinated, and in ‘68 both Martin
Luther King Jr. and Bobby Kennedy were killed
-- right as dissatisfaction with the Vietnam
War was peaking. Countries like China and
India were struggling to feed billions. Ehrlich
was in the same situation as Malthus: sitting
in the country with the world’s highest
standard of living, what reasonable person
would look at all that evidence and conclude
that, y'know what? Things are actually pretty
good!
Environmentalism had also branched out from
the simple conservation of the Teddy Roosevelt
era -- by the time Rachel Carson published
“Silent Spring” in 1962, which detailed
threats from pesticides used in agriculture
including DDT, a radical movement was already
happening. David Attenborough said that her
book changed the scientific world the most
behind only Darwin’s “Origin of Species”
-- and it opened up the floodgates not only
on exposing problems in the environment, but
rushing to fix them.
Also in 1968, ecologist Garrett Hardin published
“The Tragedy of the Commons,” which tapped
the metaphor of a public, unregulated plot
of land used rationally by individuals to
the point of total obliteration. Hardin wrote,
"Freedom in a commons brings ruin to all.”
-- and the message was that left to our own
devices, we were gonna destroy everything.
Modifying human behavior is hard -- the simplest
solution was restricting the ability to make
humans at all, and if we didn’t do it ourselves,
nature would end up doing it for us.
In the 1969 essay “Eco-Catastrophe,” Ehrlich
wrote that. “The shape of the population
growth curve is one familiar to biologists”
-- because like butterflies who interact with
and depend on their environment, populations
swell and shrink based on what that environment
can provide. He called it the “outbreak-crash
sequence” in which populations rise in times
of abundance and crash -- or completely disappear
-- when that abundance stops. A year later
he wrote in Audubon that “We’ve had most
of the outbreak -- what remains is mainly
the crash.” The world population at that
time was 3.7 billion and growing at a steady
2% per year, which put it on pace to reach
7 billion in 50 years.
Malthus had already outlined two types of
interventions to defuse what would eventually
become Ehrlich’s Population Bomb: preventative
checks and positive checks. A preventative
check is an act that controls population by
reducing fertility rates: deciding not to
have kids, limiting the number of children
parents can have -- like China’s former
one-child policy -- and the wider availability
of both contraception and abortion.
A positive check is actually… not that positive.
It’s something that limits the human lifespan,
like war, disease, famine -- or murder. It
can be an active or passive de-populator.
And you might be surprised at how many academics
were happy to mete out misery in the name
of eco-justice.
In their 1967 book “Famine! 1975,” brothers
William and Paul Paddock proposed that the
United States should limit its foreign food
aid based on the social behavior of countries
with growing populations. They categorized
Egypt and India as “can’t be saved.”
So, no food for them. Pakistan scored higher
-- the Paddocks thought they did deserve some
food. And the idea to withhold food in an
effort to encourage -- or really, punish -- behavior
was typified by President Lyndon Johnson’s
decision not to send food aid to India during
the Bihar Famine of 1966. He told an advisor,
“I’m not going to piss away foreign aid
in nations where they refuse to deal with
their own population problems.”
Ehrlich supported food punishment. He said,
“I have been citing the Paddocks’ work
in all my recent talks on the population crisis,”
and he called food punishment “coercion
for a good cause” because India was “hopeless.”
It was India that actually inspired Ehrlich
to start thinking deeply about The Population
Bomb. He had traveled to Delhi in 1965 with
his family, and what he saw was like a reboot
of London in the time of Malthus:
“My wife and daughter and I were returning
to our hotel in an ancient taxi. The seats
were hopping with fleas. The only functional
gear was third. As we crawled through the
city, we entered a crowded slum area. The
temperature was well over 100, and the air
was a haze of dust and smoke. The streets
seemed alive with people. People eating, people
watching, people sleeping. People visiting,
arguing, and screaming. People thrusting their
hands through the taxi window, begging. People
defecating and urinating. People clinging
to buses. People herding animals. People,
people, people, people. As we moved slowly
through the mob, hand horn squawking, the
dust, noise, heat, and cooking fires gave
the scene a hellish aspect.”
Ehrlich knew something had to be done.
65 years ago Leonard Read detailed the seemingly
IMPOSSIBLE global cooperation that led to
the creation of a single pencil. Think about
everything involved in production: growing
and logging the cedar, mining the graphite,
truck drivers hauling it all and a guy in
a lighthouse guiding shipping vessels into
port, it’s millions of people uniting on
their own to make a simple little thing. And
he had no idea the Foundation for Economic
Education he created would turn his unique
perspective into YouTube videos.
Their Unscene series investigates the stories
behind film, television, and pop culture -- they
just released a video about how Disney caved
to Chinese pressure to suppress an incredible
Martin Scorcese film about the Dalai Lama.
And their animated Common Sense Soapbox channel
reveals how the world really works. You can
also check out Invisible Hands, a crash course
in economics hosted by… me.
Thanks again to the Foundation for Economic
Education for supporting this video -- click
the link to their channel in the description
below. And if you can handle unique analysis
of complex systems of human behavior -- throw
them a sub.
Coercion wasn’t off the table for Ehrlich
and his colleagues, based on a tenet that
parents did not have a natural right to have
children in the first place. He toyed with
a worldwide limit of 2 children per set of
parents. Hardin agreed, saying, “The freedom
to breed is intolerable,” but warned that
“we ought not say anything foolish about
coercion” -- because trying to control people
by force would hurt the movement.
In The Population Bomb, Ehrlich said that
the government should take “whatever steps
are necessary to establish a reasonable population
size in the United States,” with a “Department
of Population and Environment” that could
fund research into “mass sterilizing agents.”
Forced sterilization was an option for him
-- and so was introducing temporary infertility
agents in public drinking water. He said that
humanity “will wake up one day to find out
that compulsory birth control offers the only
hope of survival.”
Some of his allies became increasingly nervous
about the implications of Ehrlich’s more
radical ideas, including members of the group
he founded called Zero Population Growth -- which
still exists, now called Population Connection
-- when they realized that the targets of
their global sterilization efforts were not
going to be well-educated, well-off white
people.
But Ehrlich wasn’t the only one sounding
the alarm on a grand scale. 100 politicians,
diplomats, economists, and business leaders
had founded The Club of Rome in 1965, and
their 1972 “The Limits to Growth: A Report
for the Club of Rome’s Project on the Predicament
of Mankind” presented an MIT computer model
factoring in "population, food production,
industrialization, pollution, and consumption
of nonrenewable natural resources."
They called for an absolute halt to economic
growth, warning that without it, industrial
production would collapse, population would
‘suffer a catastrophic decline.’ and the
air, sea and land would be “polluted beyond
redemption.” And the right time to intervene
wasn’t today, it was actually yesterday,
because “the collapse will not come gradually,
but with awesome suddenness, with no way of
stopping it.”
The movement’s most radical ideas became
reality in India as part of a forced sterilization
program in 1975. The BBC described the initiative:
“The drive to sterilise began in the 1970s
when, encouraged by loans amounting to tens
of millions of dollars from the World Bank,
the Swedish International Development Authority
and the UN Population Fund, India embarked
on an ambitious population control programme.
During the 1975 Emergency - when civil liberties
were suspended - Sanjay Gandhi, son of the
former Prime Minister Indira Gandhi, began
what was described by many as a ‘gruesome
campaign’ to sterilise poor men. There were
reports of police cordoning off villages and
virtually dragging the men to surgery.”
6.5 million Indian men were sterilized in
one year -- which was 15 times more than the
Nazis sterilized -- and about 2,000 of those
men died from surgical complications.
In The Population Bomb’s chapter called
“What Needs to Be Done?” Ehrlich writes:
“When we suggested sterilizing all Indian
males with three or more children, he should
have encouraged the Indian government to go
ahead with the plan. We [the United States]
should have volunteered logistic support in
the form of helicopters, vehicles, and surgical
instruments. We should have sent doctors to
aid in the program by setting up centers for
training paramedical personnel to do vasectomies.
Coercion? Perhaps, but coercion in a good
cause.”
His priority was to systematically eliminate
the world's fastest-growing populations -- which
were almost exclusively poor and non-white.
Even in his days of population concern, Julian
Simon had a softer approached than Ehrlich
or The Club of Rome: he argued that avoiding
a birth cost a developing nation about $5,
and that it would save $114 -- which he called
“a fantastic bargain” -- and proposed
offering payments to families not to have
children as a mutually-agreeable preventative
check. His idea rewarded people for their
choices instead of sterilizing them against
their will.
But Simon eventually started to realize that
people didn’t work like butterflies.
When he studied family dynamics and their
economic rationalism, he found that increased
income drove different behaviors among families
-- small families used additional money to
have larger families, and larger families
didn’t. Education levels had a marked effect
on reproduction, and still do. He looked to
works from Simon Kuznets and Richard Easterlin,
who concluded that a larger population means
more creators and innovators, and Ester Boserup’s
work that showed population density determines
the type and scale of agricultural production
and its efficiency. Simon realized that population
growth was much more complex than Ehrlich
made it out to be -- and not simply subject
to the conceptual Human Impact equation that
Ehrlich created, which was Impact = Population
x Affluence x Technology (I = P*A*T).
But Ehrlich was the guy everyone wanted to
talk to. He was young, attractive, and highly
charismatic -- which made him totally unlike
most academics. He was really funny and likable
as he detailed humanity’s impending doom
-- which is why he was a guest on The Tonight
Show over twenty times. Here he is with Johnny
Carson talking about why he thinks the benefit
of a growing population just… isn’t really
there:
Ehrlich: “Why don't we try doing a really
good job with 4 billion people? See if we
can do that. After we’ve got 4 billion people
well taken care of, in a clean environment
with good health, and everybody’s fed, and
everybody has opportunities and so on, then
we can say, well, gee, alright, maybe we can
do with 5… well, what would be the advantage
of 5? Well, there would be another half a
billion women, for instance, which I would
find…”
Carson: “Well, you’d like that!”
Ehrlich: “Yeah, right” [audience laughter]
“I’d just as soon have the 4 billion taken
care of right first.” [audience claps]
Carson: “Yeah, I think you’re right. I
think so.”
Ehrlich was masterful at presenting the science
of demographics and environmental impact in
moral and emotional terms. Do you want kids
to starve? Well… no. Do you want to perpetuate
human suffering? No. Do you want to see the
destruction of Earth, the human race, and
all plant and animal life? I don't know. PROBABLY
NOT.
And he fomented guilt, too -- especially among
high-consumption societies like the United
States and Western Europe. Is your standard
of living worth the price the rest of the
world pays?
In “The Bet,” Paul Sabin writes that Ehrlich’s
brand of rhetoric played a significant part
in whipping up Neo-Malthusian fervor. He points
to a review of Ehrlich’s 1970 book “Population,
Resources, Environment: Issues in Human Ecology”
by Roger Revelle, who founded Harvard’s
Center for Population Studies, that highlights
Ehrlich’s use of incendiary language:
“Staggering, sobering, disaster (three times),
enormously, drastically, catastrophic, dramatically,
tremendous, highly lethal, extremely dangerous
(twice), especially virulent, more severe,
extremely fortunate, extremely vulnerable,
almost total, high potential, renewed spectre,
not gruesome enough, colossal hazard, biological
doomsday, superlethal, and disastrously effective”
Revelle noted what he called “apocalyptic
adverbs and adjectives” because that list
I just read appeared in only four pages out
of a book of over 300.
Ehrlich had become a celebrity on TV, was
writing in Playboy -- and Julian Simon was
not happy.
The 70’s brought a series of energy crises
starting with the 1973 oil embargo that resulted
in a 43% increase in the price of gas, gas
rationing in California based on license plate
numbers, and serious fears about dependence
on fossil fuels. So Ehrlich was looking pretty
smart -- but Simon insisted that population
growth and its global problems should “thrill
rather than frighten us.”
How!? How could he look at a world in crisis
and possibly think that?
Simon had spent the 70’s writing about all
the reasons the Ehrlich-style doomsdayers
were wrong: wrong about their models, wrong
about humans, and really, just wrong about
the way the whole world works.
And he was writing, seemingly, to no one.
In a 1997 interview with Wired -- titled “The
Doomslayer” -- he said seeing Ehrlich tout
such damaging theories “absolutely drove
me out of my skull… Here was a guy reaching
a vast audience, leading this juggernaut of
environmentalist hysteria, and I felt utterly
helpless. What could I do? Go talk to five
people?"
Well, the truth of the matter is even those
5 people didn’t want to hear that between
1800 and 1980, the price of wheat in the United
States dropped precipitously despite the population
growing by about 4,500%. It didn’t matter
that Simon found that population did not actually
increase geometrically, and birthrates had
even begun to fall in developed countries
-- including below “replacement rate,”
which is the minimum number of babies born
to maintain current levels of population.
In 1950, global life expectancy was 45. By
1980, it was 61 -- and that happened due to
better medicine, better technology, greater
food production, and greater wealth. That’s
about a 35% longer life in 30 years.
All his frustration led to an article that
brought Simon and his optimism into the international
debate over humanity’s future. In the June
27, 1980 issue of Science, Simon published
“Resources, Population, Environment: An
Oversupply of False Bad News.” And the introductory
summary says it all:
“False bad news about population growth,
natural resources, and the environment is
published widely in the face of contradictory
evidence. For example, the world supply of
arable land has actually been increasing,
the scarcity of natural resources including
food and energy has been decreasing, and basic
measures of U.S. environmental quality show
positive trends. The aggregate data show no
long-run negative effect of population growth
upon standard of living. Models that embody
forces omitted in the past, especially the
influence of population size upon productivity
increase, suggest a long-run positive effect
of additional people.”
Simon completely decimated claims that arable
land had decreased worldwide -- instead, he
noted that cultivated land was rising at 1%
per year. He showed that farmers in industrialized
nations were producing more food on less land
-- as populations grew, people were getting
better at farming and technology was making
it cheaper and easier with fewer people involved.
To the charge that the world increasingly
struggled with food, Simon showed that per
capita food production had also grown at about
1% per year.
Now It wasn’t good news, yay yay yay, cotton
candy and sunshine, all around, and it never
will be. Simon was honest about that. But
he made the distinction that the food problems
in vulnerable countries were overwhelmingly
the result of restricted markets, war, and
political instability. He called out The New
York Times, the United Nations, the World
Bank -- and, of course, Ehrlich. And he lamented
the reliance on faulty computer models that
delivered grim, and ultimately wrong, projections
about our future. He concluded that:
“Population growth and productivity increase
are not independent forces running a race.
Rather, additional persons cause technological
advances by inventing, adapting, and diffusing
new productive knowledge.”
He also wasn’t the first to challenge Malthus
and Ehrlich on these grounds -- and he had
some unexpected allies throughout history.
Karl Marx called Malthus a “plagiarist,”
a “sycophant,” and a “reverend scribbler,”
and Engels refuted Malthus’s concept of
nature’s inevitable processes, writing that,
“... the determining factor in history…
is the production and reproduction of the
immediate essentials of life.” Marx and
Engels saw the solution in a tightly-controlled
collectivism that would eventually become
Communism, while Simon pointed to the power
of freedom and markets -- but they all believed
that the way we organize society can address
population problems that seem hopeless. But
aren't.
Economist Henry George stated the difference
most simply in his 1879 “Progress and Poverty,”
saying, "Both the jayhawk and the man eat
chickens; but the more jayhawks, the fewer
chickens, while the more men, the more chickens."
Monarch butterflies eat nectar produced from
flowering plants. If there’s not enough
nectar to support the monarch butterfly population,
some of them die until it reaches a sustainable
level. But if humans have restricted access
to a particular resource -- like, corn or
something -- or it becomes too expensive,
we can just use something else. Simon argued
that humanity has two superpowers: adaptability
and innovation. We can invent, we can improve,
and we can substitute, all of which constitutes
less of a threat to resources than Ehrlich
thought.
Because, to Simon, those finite resources
aren’t nearly as finite as they seem. He
used copper as an example, saying that we
can’t calculate future quantities of copper
because: “new lodes, new methods of mining
copper, and variations in grades of copper
lodes; because copper can be made from other
metals; and because of the vagueness of the
boundaries within which copper might be found
– including the sea, and other planets.
Even less possible is a reasonable calculation
of the amount of future services of the sort
we are now accustomed to get from copper,
because of recycling and because of the substitution
of other materials for copper, as in the case
of the communications satellite.”
Translation, we are good at finding more,
we’re getting more efficient at extracting
it, we’re using it more smartly, and how
we use it now doesn’t have any bearing on
how we’ll use it in the future -- if we
use it at all.
Simon wrote in Science that we have so much
bad news about the world because that’s
where the funding is for researchers -- and
that late night talk shows don’t have guests
who talk about everything getting better.
But he also said that the “cumulative nature
of exponential growth models” have the “power
to seduce and bewitch,” especially because
so many people compare the present with the
potential future -- idealized or awful -- instead
of comparing the present to the past.
Simon and his growing ranks of optimists were
derided as adhering to “cornucopianism”
-- referencing the Greek mythological horn
of abundance that produced food and never
ran out. Ehrlich said Simon was “like the
guy who jumps off the Empire State Building
and says how great things are going so far
as he passes the 10th floor.”
Ehrlich insisted that not only did we have
finite resources, but that we were using them
up fast, while Simon was effectively arguing
that resources were endless -- and it didn’t
help that he wrote that humanity’s only
real limit was the theoretical total weight
of the universe. To Ehrlich, we were doomed;
to Simon, humans not only had the capacity
to address our problems, but that we’d come
out even better than before we had them. It
was kind of a big difference.
So the battle lines had finally been drawn
-- and it was time to make a wager on the
future of the human race. It was time for
the bet.
In Social Science Quarterly, Simon said he’d
like to take that bet with Ehrlich about England
still existing 20 years on -- but instead,
he proposed "to stake $10,000 ... on my belief
that the cost of non-government-controlled
raw materials (including grain and oil) will
not rise in the long run."
Simon said that Ehrlich could choose any 5
raw materials he wanted -- Simon left it up
to him -- and that they would track the prices
of each commodity over the course of 10 years.
On September 29, 1980, Ehrlich agreed to a
reduced wager of $1,000, putting $200 into
each of 5 resources he and his colleagues
had predicted would rise in price over the
coming decade: copper, chromium, nickel, tin,
and tungsten. If the inflation-adjusted prices
went up, Simon would pay Ehrlich their difference
in values between 1980 and 1990. If their
prices went down, Simon would win the bet
and Ehrlich would pay the difference.
Copper has been used in various capacities
for over 10,000 years, from primitive tools
to modern conductors. Chromium is a component
to stainless steel, and it’s why your dad’s
wrenches are hard and don’t rust. Nickel
is one of four ferromagnetic elements; we
use it now in the rechargeable batteries of
electric vehicles. Tin is important for alloys
and plating -- which is why plated steel cans
were referred to as “tin cans.” Tungsten
is extremely hard and dense, and it’s necessary
in x-ray tubes and welding. These 5 materials
presented a cross-section of nature-dependent
human activity that Ehrlich was convinced
would force demand and scarcity to collide.
The 1980s saw a dramatic policy shift in the
United States under Ronald Reagan, who advocated
for a freer market in line with Simon’s
optimism. Fears about endangered species became
real, holes in the Ozone layer threatened
to increase exposure to ultraviolet radiation,
and the Exxon Valdez oil spill dominated the
news at the end of the decade. The threat
of nuclear war still loomed, and a nuclear
disaster in Chernobyl came 7 years after Three
Mile Island. So things did not seem awesome.
But on September 29, 1990, it was time for
someone to pay up.
In 1980, the price of chromium was $3.90 per
pound. In 1990, it was $3.70. Tin dropped
by half from $8.72 to $3.88. Three of the
five metals had gone down in price despite
inflation, and the other two both fell in
inflation-adjusted terms.
Simon won the bets on all 5 of the chosen
metals -- but more importantly to him, Ehrlich
and his doomsday philosophy lost.
In October of 1990, a check from Wells Fargo
Bank in the amount of $576.07 arrived in Julian
Simon’s mailbox. There was no note, and
the check was signed by Anne Ehrlich -- Paul’s
wife.
In his book “The Ultimate Resource,” Julian
Simon wrote:
“Adding more people causes problems. But
people are also the means to solve these problems.
The main fuel to speed the world’s progress
is our stock of knowledge; the brakes are
our lack of imagination and unsound social
regulations of these activities. The ultimate
resource is people—especially skilled, spirited,
and hopeful young people endowed with liberty—who
will exert their wills and imaginations for
their own benefits, and so inevitably they
will benefit the rest of us as well.”
It was truly a triumph of hope and optimism
over doom and gloom -- or did Simon just get
lucky?
A 2009 paper called “Luck or Skill? An Examination
of the Ehrlich-Simon Bet” reveals that had
the bet been run one more time from 1990-2000,
Simon would’ve triumphed again -- but had
the wager taken place for any of the possible
98 ten-year periods between 1900 and 2007,
Ehrlich would’ve won 61.2% of the time.
So maybe Ehrlich was right? Naaaaaah.
Actually, the data shows a massive crash in
commodities prices following World War I -- which
means they spent the rest of the century slowly
rising back to their former levels, creating
an artificial bias toward Ehrlich’s rising
prices theory and proving Simon’s exact
point about the power of human cooperation
-- or in the case of a World War, the lack
of cooperation -- to determine how we use
and value resources.
It’s easy to look at the results of the
Ehrlich-Simon wager and scoff at the loser
-- and it’s even easier to revisit failed
doomsday predictions of a disappearing England
and worldwide famine killing billions and
laugh at how wrong it all was. It's much harder
to understand why those predictions happen
in the first place -- and why it's completely
natural to think everything is bad and getting
worse. It's why the doomsayers are so seductive
and popular, and why the doomslayers aren't
just ignored -- they're hated.
In 2016, Swedish physician Hans Rosling was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. He began
writing “Factfulness: Ten Reasons We’re
Wrong About the World,” as what he called
his “last battle in my life-long mission
to fight devastating ignorance” -- it was
published in 2018 a year after he died. Rosling
detailed 10 human instincts that conspire
to convince us that the world is forever going
in the wrong direction -- which can inform
devastatingly-wrong reactions to our problems.
The first is the “Gap Instinct,” which
is to consider the differences between the
top and the bottom rather than focusing on
the majority or whether all levels of society
are improving in spite of relative differences.
And he argues that our “Negative Instinct”
programs us not to bother noticing improvements
at all.
Our “Straight Line Instinct” causes us
to assume that our current trends will continue
exactly as they are right now rather than
accelerating or decelerating, and our “Fear
Instinct” distorts our perception of risk
to make us overvalue possible negatives.
Our “Size Instinct” makes us feel overwhelmed
by the sheer scale of a problem as our “Generalization
Instinct” lumps all our problems together
as being equally-threatening -- and our “Destiny
Instinct” makes us feel like none of our
problems ever get solved even though they
tend to get better slowly.
Our “Single-Perspective Instinct” hyper-focuses
on just one possible solution rather than
considering many solutions that work in combination,
and our “Blame Instinct” makes us focus
on the bad guys who we’re convinced are
responsible for the problem. But the most
threatening might be the “Urgency Instinct,”
which drives us to feel that there's an impending
catastrophe if we don’t do something immediately
rather than one step at a time.
Only a single comma separates “Do something,
stupid!” from “Do something stupid.”
Ehrlich was 0 for 5 on his bet with Julian
Simon, but he’s 10 for 10 on Rosling’s
checklist of instinctual pathologies.
Paul Ehrlich is now in his 90’s, and he’s
vibrant, energetic, and still insisting that
he’s right -- or that he was never that
wrong. In January of this year, Ehrlich tweeted
after being featured on 60 Minutes that, “If
I'm always wrong so is science, since my work
is always peer-reviewed, including the POPULATION
BOMB and I've gotten virtually every scientific
honor. Sure I've made some mistakes, but no
basic ones.”
Elon Musk disagrees. In June, he said that,
“Paul Ehrlich has done immense damage to
humanity. Immense. I despise him.”
In April of 2023, Ehrlich gave an interview
at Stanford in which he said that he wouldn’t
deny anyone the opportunity to have children,
but that:
“... if you have 10 children, you’re an
evil person trying to basically destroy the
world.”
The birth rate in Somalia is 7.5 times higher
than in South Korea -- but it isn’t clear
whether Ehrlich thinks Somalians are 7.5 times
more evil.
In 1981, the year after the Ehrlich-Simon
wager -- and the year in which Simon’s “The
Ultimate Resource" came out -- 88% of the
population of China lived in extreme poverty.
Deng Xioping’s market reforms then fueled
tremendous economic growth and an increased
standard of living. China’s extreme poverty
rate today is under 1%, there are no longer
any restrictions on reproduction, and China
has more billionaires than any other country
in the world.
In 1980, the average daily caloric intake
globally was 2,487; today it’s 2,928. In
India, it rose from 1,994 50 years ago to
2,533 today -- and in a long list of countries,
we now have a new problem of consuming too
many calories.
Life expectancy globally was just 61 years
in 1980; today it’s about 73.
In 2022, about 630,000 people worldwide died
from AIDS-related illnesses -- down 69% from
about 2 million per year just 20 years ago,
and you'll now find TV commercials for competing
commercials for combination antiretroviral
drugs that reduce the HIV virus to undetectable
levels.
In 1998, Julian Simon was jumping rope on
his deck. The phone rang, and his wife went
upstairs to answer it. It was their daughter
Judith with news that she was pregnant with
Julian’s first grandchild.
A grandchild that was not just one more mouth
to feed, but another human with potentially
unlimited creative capacity -- a brand new
human mind added on to the 6 billion of the
time, one with the power to innovate, to identify
new problems and to solve the old ones -- or
maybe just one more human to make life worth
living.
Not an insect whose primitive cerebral ganglia
draws it into a flame to its own death — but
a person who can harness that flame to cook
food, heat their houses, and smelt ore from
the rocks they dig up. Julian Simon’s grandchild
would be one more soul in a world he knew
got a little better every day, even when it
didn’t feel that way.
Julian’s wife ran down the stairs to give
him the great news. She found him dead on
the living room floor. He’d had a heart
attack at 65.
Paul Ehrlich’s Population Bomb theory was
right -- about butterflies. Since his 1980
bet with Simon, the Western Monarch Butterfly
has seen a population reduction of over 95%.
We cleared forests for farming, and the milkweed
that Monarchs feed on flourished. Herbicides
to control weeds in crops shrunk available
milkweed, and butterfly populations were devastated.
But we’ve responded by doing exactly what
Simon said we would: creating a rehabilitation
plan that includes planting 1.3 billion milkweed
stems through the Central Migratory Flyway.
Everyone knows we are mired in problems and
the consequences of our progress — but the
one way to avoid armageddon is to think beyond
the doom, to resist the siren song of our
most basic instincts, and to make use of our
one ultimate finite resource… you.
And as always, thanks for watching.
"Because it has been agreed by the nations
of the world that the Earth can no longer
sustain a continuously increasing population,
child-bearing is herewith forbidden."